I want to talk to you a little bit about
HMOs and raising finance so firstly what
is a HMO so HMO is a house of multiple
occupancy so you've got three or more
people living within the same property
generally that's by renting rooms
separately to three separate tenants
there are on separate tenancy agreements
why do you love HMO so much because I
master them because they make a lot of
money so I can't because here's the
thing the houses we were looking at
earlier you rent them out for five
hundred-pound you'll be left with maybe
250 300 Panama's profit 300 Panamint
profit you need a lot of houses to
become financially to become financially
free excuse me how many houses when you
need to become financially free all
through in Japan each at least ten
whereas if I hate you mo how much see
how much do you are on average HMOs make
you profit each month my larger ones
make about 1,200 a month profit profit
yeah probably after a bit so what's your
secret man basically you've got
obviously you've got a look in the right
kind of areas you've got to know what
you've got obviously taking these
trainings these kind of things you've
got to know what you're dealing with
you've got to know the rules and
regulation so once you know that it's
fairly easy what are the two big rules
and regulations to do with HMOs regard
regarding safety and things know
regarding what are the two things that
you need so one would be planning of
course yes so regarding yeah so article
four being where you can't set up HMOs
in a specific area without having to get
planning permission and the general a
certain city certain borrowers have set
them up and you know basically tapering
off certain areas where you can't just
set them up anymore you know in areas
where article four doesn't exist you can
just basically set up these you can get
general generic house so effectively and
if yeah so you don't need to licensure
HMOs have got four people or less if
it's got five people you need to get HMO
license from the council yeah so that's
obviously very
so if you need a lot how do you get a
license for a HMO so let's say you want
to get a big HMO how do you get a
license how do you go about that so you
just basically you print the stuff off
online you fill it out it's fairly
rudimentary it is pretty light they want
to know every fine detail but it's not
hard one you know it's just kind of
tedious once you've got it done send it
to the council you send obviously a
check and they might come out and
inspect it but you're not criminal yeah
so yeah so the bedrooms are a minimum of
so the bedrooms are a minimum each
bedrooms a minimum 6.52 square me is a
square foot yes you took notes on the
train in C and but you so okay so the
rooms have got to be seventy squared fee
you need you need fire doors smoke
alarms things like that and then you get
a license article for means if there's
article four in the area you cannot earn
any property into a HMO unless you have
to go through a whole horrible process
of planning and they'll even then they
might decline you we love article four
why do we love it why I know you love
article four so if you basically if
you've got HTML already set up in an
area an article 4 comes in you've got
grandfather rights it's called so your
HMO can still operate in that area and
because no other HMOs can be set up in
that area the price what you know the
basically the capital appreciation your
HMO the price that investors will pay
for your HMO if you were to sell it is
that it goes up massively so article
fall if you're if you've already
invested in area ask or force a big win
are you saying you basically saying that
you look for areas that are not article
four yeah but the council have to give
twelve months notice before they make an
area article for so you find properties
that are not article four that are about
to become our do before you buy a house
you run it as a multi let yes and then
when article four comes in you have the
grandfather rights automatic planning
permission all your competition is
killed off yes you're the
value of your house shoots up your winds
go up because you've got no more
competition
boom shocka yeah it's article fall it's
a massive wind when it comes in so we
need two guys twenty-two like you know
twenty-two and your HMOs are shooting up
in value yes yes so what tell me how do
you do that how do you legally borrow
people's money and buy properties like
is that even legit yeah 100% so you
basically you work you create a network
and you work with people who have money
and you discuss with them about sort of
deals you've got and then they use their
money to invest in the property so thing
is because you're so smart and you've
been on the training and you've invested
in yourself you're valuable now so I
don't want to invest with you like he
knows all the areas article for non
article for he's researched because
you've been through the Academy yeah a
hundred percent so and then now because
you've been for the Academy you're
valuable so people yeah yes so obviously
having gone on the trainings these kind
of things I've learned specific
strategies have learned a lot about you
know deep into HTML license aids every
all the specifics and Samuel said I'm
seen as a valuable person and investors
want to invest with me so it's fairly
easy to raise the finance I need for
these kind of deals yeah John came to my
office uninvited barge did yeah I mean
you got to do what you got to do when
you trying to raise finance I just saw
get trained straight down here and you
know just seeping dirty soon man
do you want me to do I just want to
pitch yeah let you know pitch it you can
hear me out absolutely think and know
one consumer can do people come to my
office without an appointment I get sent
home although I do live with passion you
know I've tried everything but say
barges into my offices this is all in
YouTube and people said oh it's fake
fake because we were because we were
recording when he came in you know guess
what I record everything even right now
I mean this is being recorded I film
everything for my own purposes so the
cameras are on my PA locks the door
you've got a visitor who John I haven't
got an appointment John rabe oh don't
play Bach and then I think John well
this is a good few months ago I'm
thinking with John's on the Academy he
really did can't be doing this but I'm
curious now Sid Bream it he comes in he
starts pitching a deal to me that's
basically asking for money yeah I mean
you got to do what you got to do so it's
hard to say no because he's everything
I've taught him is not using against me
I don't remember if I gave you the money
in the end I I decided that the sort of
deal I found I can find loads of these
and I thought that you know for this one
I'll just assault while sterile eights
on YouTube he just poured three thousand
panic cash and just gave it to him yeah
yeah that's what happens when you're
valuable why would he work a day in his
life again why would you need a job yeah
I mean if each yes true that's true
I can make more money doing this what do
you family think of what you're doing
because I know your dad was very
skeptical yes my dad was very skeptical
about it I joined the Academy also got a
low enjoying the Academy no but he
obviously found out it wasn't
particularly happy about it that kind of
thing but I told him about it I wanted
to work with my dad my dad's also
interested in you know financial freedom
getting out of his job he was very
skeptical about it all that kind of
thing so I got him to a crash course and
then he sort of saw the like with it all
and he's like fully on board
and I work on opportunist I say if
you've got skeptical friends and family
you don't have to worry about working on
them just send them to me because I owe
people so Samuel you just brainwash
people yeah I do because you your real
brain needs a good wash you wash your
armpits every morning why not wash your
brain from time to time I'll brain wash
the heck out of you
it'd certainly work with my dad like
used like a changed man with this off
under the skepticism of things yes he's
just cleaning out all the muck there's
seven lies you know all this stuff
you're stupid you're too young get all
this stuff and I'm just like no knocking
cleaning the brain out and you down a
little brain cleaned and now you he did
a joint venture with you yes I've done
joint ventures my dad as well I on a
couple of HMOs so now is saying I want
to joint venture with you John because
you're on the Academy I can see how much
of a you've got like that's it's
incredible so talk to us a little bit
about the management side of HMOs how do
you find the tenants how do you find the
how do you how do you deal with that so
management wise leave it I definitely
work with a HMO manager in the area so
whatever area is I'll find a hate your
manager discuss with them about the best
places to invest discuss with them about
what sort of tenants I'll be getting in
that kind of area if you get a really
good - hey - my manager they might cut
you know you get along really well with
and they might come out to do certain
viewings with you say yes it's all work
then obviously lots of properties
purchased they will help me to do any
sort of like minded minded developments
or in the sense of like putting in fire
doors and from there I just kind of
leave it to them the money just kind of
rolls in so you look in you look around
about 10% it does depend on what kind of
tenants you're going for so if you're
going for sort of DSS they might charge
slightly more pops slightly harder to
work with but
DSS be sort of like benefits tenants
tenants on certain sorts of benefits you
don't work Google I it's not hard like I
type in for instance HTML managers in
Bedford or hecho mumsy and Doncaster and
they'll they'll come up and what I'll do
is obviously ring them talk to them I'll
get a sense of the person but I also go
meet them and from that I mean you can
be number HM hunches in the day you just
go to the area meet a few and then you
get a sense of who's the best one that
kind of thing and then from there I
obviously choose one you just work with
them next is as well what advice would
you give to someone that was thinking
about should they invest in an HMO or
should they buy a single that what would
you advise personally I mean people have
said that oh you can't get HMO mortgage
if you've not got a single let you know
before that kind of thing you know if
you've not we've not had a property for
you can't do it
we know I did like I was a I was at uni
so I some how much to do actually work
broker yeah of course okay from getting
money to anyone with a pulse it's you
know it's doable it's doable I would
100% say go with HMOs because they are
slightly hard to work in the sense that
you know they need fire doors that kind
of thing but once you've got over that
obstacle you just let the hedge fund
manager do deal with it all like you
make more money from it I would I know
that here we're very open we don't hold
back people have come from Australia so
where are you currently buying your
hiking earth so I've got HMO I've got
basically I look in the north but I'm
from Sheffield so I don't have any
specifically in Sheffield but I look
generally the north because that's where
the better return investments are and
I've got one in Burnley and then a few
in like North Lincolnshire so you know I
just thought that kind of area ya know
they all work really well there alright
typically like um they're all fall the
minute so it's not rooms no nothing yes
it's good okay maybe one or two
questions up for time or just we'll keep
it at that because don't see me sticking
around yes ma'am okay just stand up and
we'll get a mic on you I you know you
said about ask
for the council have to give 12 months
notice how would you find out that
they're giving 12 plan stages how do you
find out that they bring in the bottle
for it it's just on council if you're
networking with people and you're
looking in that specific area you just
you just kind of find these things out
so I just gave him a spreadsheet come on
I mean there are yeah there are yeah
yeah I did obviously I'm sorry but but
if you really if you ring gum if you
bring a council like what where are you
from right gang ready if you bring the
reading council and sizes are is is is
is this area currently article fourth I
say no is there any intent is there any
intention that will tell you that well
yeah it's likely there like an area just
outside there would you get article four
as well don't custard they bring an
article forward I'm reading reading is
down south ratings are already article
four but say the neighboring town will
not be likely that they could get
article for quite possibly yeah if you
or if you if you google it if you google
the neighbors name of the neighboring
town followed by article for yeah if
there's any intention it will be on the
website okay it is no okay we have a
spreadsheet on there what we share
around which is all the upcoming stuff
but yeah you just google it
don't caster is where I just bought
house yesterday which is due to be
article four in the next twelve months
certificates well thank you one more
yeah go right the very back yeah with
the gracious oh sorry go gray shirt yeah
waving your hands around like a maniac
um I just wanna ask you are your HMOs
student lets or professional let's and
if so which ones why do you prefer like
one or the other
um I don't have any professional let's
just sort of like blue collar workers
I've got a student student one and then
I have a lot of lights or DSS or
unemployed will benefit HMOs
generally i i work with return
investments so even though as
DSS HMO harder to run you make a lot
more money doing it
so because obviously is more there's a
innocence that there's less input in the
house of cheap in those areas that kind
of thing
so I'll work really with anything what
works in the areas I'm looking and which
makes a good return I would say students
aprotic students I would say are easier
than for instance DSS it depends what
sort market you want to wear and my
advice is don't try mix don't try and
mix the two so just just five you know
ask the heck to my management company
just say what Watford for in this street
what's the best and then just stick with
it what would you support a year ago if
you Danone the after joining the Academy
you'd be financially free you'd have
like ten houses or ever many houses
you've got you'd have gone to Africa and
helps dig wells and bring water to
people and ran business workshops have
dinner with Robert Kiyosaki and get to
know him personally and now be on stage
in front of over a thousand people like
would you believed it no I'd probably
laughed at you I wouldn't I wouldn't
have believed like that would be
possible if that makes sense like
obviously when I joined the Academy I
was I was obviously University or second
year university student I didn't really
have any plans about getting into
property there was nothing like that and
so the sense of obviously the the how
much I feel I've achieved in such a
short space of time you know obviously
through some yields health who Samuel
straining but it's just I mean I brought
you for out your on the addiction I can
see other Academy members around at the
back and stuff like how does it helped
you want a social because I know your
uni friends were quite negative and very
you know unsure about your property move
yeah so I mean on a social level
obviously a I've got a bit of a
different mindset to the other people my
you knew study history and politics with
me so I get on with them you know that
kind of thing but there's not really a
month there's not really a massive
connect on this kind of level of what I
want to do you know business that kind
of thing so being in the Academy put me
with people out a similar mindset put me
with sort of JV partners I'm now working
with it put me with like a whole new
group of friends basically it is like a
big family everyone has the same kind of
minds
we all want to work together and it's
just it's just amazing it's helped
obviously develop so many friendship for
me it's amazing that's great well John I
really appreciate you coming out John's
gonna be sticking around tonight you're
awesome man thank you for your support
excu in the hand
[Applause]
[Music]
you